I was thinking about my life
my accomplishments you do when you have
a big birthday and it just all kept
leading back to you
and I saw what greater accomplishment
can I ever ever have in my life than
being loved by someone who is
so magnificent by someone as incredible
as you you should probably grab a box of
tissues because Portia de Rossi and
Ellen DeGeneres just renewed their
wedding vows and it'll have you deep in
your feels it was this beautiful moment
on Tuesday Porsha's 50th birthday the
actress pulled off the ultimate surprise
shocking her wife with an impromptu vow
renewal in front of friends and family
surprise
you don't have to say anything at all
but when I was thinking about what would
make my birthday really special it was
reminding you that you're the most
important thing in the world to me in
front of family and friends we're just
really good friends and we talk about
everything and we never ever lie to each
other Ellen shared a video of the
Romantic ceremony on Instagram which
took place at their LA area home and was
officiated by her pal Kris Jenner these
two are a couple goals who continue to
amaze me with how cute they are together
a match made in heaven
two peas in a pod their love and
commitment to one another is amazing and
it makes me so happy that they have each
other to love and cherish and grow
overly Porsche entered the room wearing
the same Zach pose in wedding dress from
their 2008 nuptials as Brandy Carlisle
delivered an intimate performance
[Music]
and when Portia took the floor there
wasn't a dry eye in the place
how lucky am I to be somebody who
accepts me for exactly who I am who
loves me for exactly who I am
it's you thingy Porsha and Ellen tied
the knot in 2008 after the Supreme Court
of California legalized marriage for
same-sex couples and over the years the
two have praised each other to E.T she's
the only person I want to hang out with
like she is my best friend I just want
to be with her all the time and when it
came to renewing their vows Ellen kept
it short and super sweet I would not be
on this Earth without you you saved me
every day
thank you for saving me every day
and I'm the lucky one
[Music]